YEARS OF  OFFSIDE
IT COMES IN FRONT, AND HUSSO
SETS THE TABLE BACKLINE.
>> Darren: I GUESS IT WAS.
SHOT OFFTODAY, EACH OF THEM
HAVE PLAYED ONE NHL GAME.SCHMID.
NOW AROUNDD ON 91,
THEIR FIRST ROUND PICK, COLE
PERFETTI.
HE HAS A CRAFTY MIND. BEEN
CHALLENGING, POWER PLAY
SPONSORED BY THE IT, KEPT IN
BY FAULK.
IT WAS A GOOD PLAY, THE
PREVIOUS 3, COMES OUT OF HE DEL.
TO THE NET A
FOR PIONK.
SCHENN AND FAULK GET THE ASSISTS
ON THE GOALTHE BENCH
LOOKS LIKE HE'S HURT AFTER
HITTIN KNOW A GREAT PLAY
MAKER.
AND THEN LOWRY WRIST THE
PAD OF COMRIE.
>> Darren: LOOKED LIKE TARASENKO
MAY HAVE TAKEN A STI
YOUR RIGHT LEG AND THEN YOU'VE
GOT TO GET YOUR RIGHT LEG
UNDERNEATH YTURNOVER.
SMIT
GETS IT OFF THE GLASS AND IN. T
PLAYER:  THE O
SET UP IN HOCKEY BUZZING BACK I
ZONE, EVERYBODY ELSE IS HIS B B
OWN TEAMMATE.
AS THE PERIOD WENT ON, JOHN, IT
WAS JUST A LITTLE
THEIR LEADING GOAL SCORER WITH
23.
IN  THE
MIDDLE OF THE ICE, NO SUPPORT O
ASSIST ON THE GOAL BYRONGLY.
>> John: YES, DILLON COULD NOT
HOLD IT IN.
AND NOW NATE SCHMIDT BACK OFFSI.
>> Darren:n:OU
KNOW, BE SOME KIND OF ROCKET
SCIENTIST TO FIGURE OUT THAT
THAT WAS NOT THE BEST EFFORT  E.
>> John: NOW CENTERED, O'REILLY
A SHOT AND THAT CALL.
>> Darren: GOOD HIT BY VLADY BY
THEN MIKKOLA COMES
>> John: A OUT PIONK
>> Referee: WINNIPEGLOWRY.
A  CENTER,
NOW FOR SCHENN.
THE STICK OF DUBOIS.
BUT REGARDLESS, IT'S STILL A
TRIP.